MARK MIRCHANDANI: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that
you didn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see Real-Time
Stream Analytics with Google
Cloud Dataflow, Common
Use Cases and Patterns,
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You might be asking
yourself, what
makes handling streaming
data different?
Well, when you've
got lots of data--
and I mean lots of data--
constantly coming in,
you can't just process it
the same way as a large batch
dataset.
We need to make sure we
handle the data appropriately
as it comes in.
Streaming analysis tools let
us work with unbounded data
and handle challenges
such as unknown delays.
This is especially common
for mobile users and devices
that aren't always connected.
Late data will
still need to factor
into your data processing.
In addition, we
often want to work
with grouping our data
into meaningful sets
by factors like time.
This is called windowing.
And we can do this by dividing
our events into fixed time
intervals, sliding
time intervals,
or based on when a user is
active and sending events.
So knowing some of
the challenges that
make streaming analysis unique,
let's implement an example.
If we were going to build
a game with lots of events,
we can use the Google Cloud
Dataflow and the Apache Beam
SDK to do this.
We can implement data
processing with event handling,
and we'll build a pipeline
using some common patterns.
First, we'll want
to make sure we
handle each event
only once through
exactly-once processing.
We can use Google Cloud PubSub
to handle all of the events,
but we'll add in some
deduplication logic
right in Dataflow to avoid
handling the same event twice.
Next, we'll want
to make sure we can
handle bad data that comes in.
By default, Dataflow
will continuously
retry those records, because
we don't want to lose data.
Instead of that, let's
build in a system
to handle malformed
data, storing it
in BigQuery for
further analysis,
and setting up alerts in
Google Cloud Functions.
Now we know that
data won't be lost.
Even when we protect
against bad data,
sometimes additional
data comes in,
but we actually still
want to capture it.
Thankfully, BigQuery allows
for additive schema changes.
If additional data
comes in that goes
beyond our original
schema, we can
have BigQuery update the
fields without any downtime
and reinsert it.
Of course, with
all of that data,
there are other parts
of our architecture
that might have important
information for our game
events.
In order to enrich our data with
some real-time denormalization,
we'll add a step
for grabbing data
from another source,
such as Bigtable.
During the data flow
processing, we'll
make a connection to
Bigtable, pull out
the information we need,
and then add that back
into our pipeline.
Finally, let's do some user
behavior analysis on our data.
Now that we've got all
of our enriched data,
we want to look at windowing
our data with sessions so
that we know when the
user is playing the game.
Also, grouping by
user ID lets us fully
analyze what events a user
generates during an activity
session.
Now that is a streaming
analytics solution.
In the video, Ryan
gives more detail
about how you can implement
these, as well as a great use
case from Sky, a television
provider in Europe that
saw some fantastic
benefits when switching
from an on-prem solution
to using Dataflow and Beam.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
click on the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]